you are sitting here with the knowledge
of us having an actual business meeting
yeah and me giving actual advice as an
investor
nicely
I only got 15 minutes and ended up being
a two hour Jam
it's the version of me that's Gary
vaynerchuk not garyvee when I'm making
content I can only go so deep on a
podcast or a quick piece of tick tock
like you just it is what it is right
obviously the podcast goes deeper
dailyvee was able to go deeper but
there's nothing like an actual business
meeting where we're talking about
private information these are actual
meetings and I you know for me I've
always been more proud of that version
of me than all of the sizzle to me I'm
proud that I'm an actual businessman
it's how I associate with my own self
and yeah I mean I think for everyone
sitting here with their Ambitions and
things of that nature like real [ __ ]
takes time to build it's supposed to be
hard if you're trying to live a one
percent of a one percent life what's
good everyone what's going on to see you
what a vibe What A vibe all right
you've been saying that 97 of all nft
projects are going to go to zero you've
been saying this is the dawn of nfts we
are not encrypt the winter we're in
crypto frostbite I heard that earlier
um let's talk about the state of the of
our industry what do you see what's
happening and how do we how the [ __ ] do
we get out of this
I think we get out of it with patience
it's just the same reason I spoke about
the 97 98 that I kept throwing out a
year ago it was just because there was
so much greed and short behavior and
that's a you know that's okay humans are
flawed and that was understandable and
luckily unlike so many of the beautiful
people here in the audience I've got
gray hairs and I saw this movie in 1997
to 2001 it was called the internet
with the internet though the companies
had to go public and they were IPOs and
not as many people were playing in it
and people that were playing in it were
professional investors and that was
Carnage with this there was so many more
young people in it who'd never really
been professional investors everybody
had access to it and so my anticipation
was that it was going to be much more
challenging and so that happened because
the greed was so heavy the the
correction happened so quickly but then
there was also macro situations let's
not pretend that Wall Street hasn't been
hammered in the last year let's not
pretend that walls that real estate's
about to get completely annihilated
inflation's been difficult the biggest
tech companies in the world are laying
people off by the by the hundreds by the
thousands so we're in an economic
correction this was already wildly
speculative and new and we get out of it
the same way the internet got out of it
in 2001 to 2004 Allah lot of the
websites you know the slash dots the
friendsters they became the previews to
the reddits and the Instagrams and I
think here in the next 36 months
including many people in this room and
definitely people that are down here in
Miami that over the next 36 months
people are now going to build meaningful
things instead of fast things for Fast
Cash and then we'll look up in seven or
eight years and be like oh [ __ ] it was
2023 when this started really getting
built so let's talk about that because
investment Facebook
Uber
first speaks the guy on selling wines
right what does it take to build a
business on fundamentals knowing what
you know today it feels like to me yeah
your kids are looking at any time it's
continued backwards they're raising
Capital off of that free product free
Revenue they're getting these massive
evaluations that are literally hyped up
taxpayer what does it take to build a
business on fundamentals
building a business on fundamentals and
and what's interesting about that is
like that's what it is right I I did a
lot of investing last year in web 3
really looking for my Amazon or my eBay
because I knew that we were in this
place but I also knew and still believe
that four to seven of the projects and
four or seven of the companies that were
rolling last year they might be in down
rounds they might not be as valued as
much their floor price may not be as
good but I do believe in seven or eight
years there'll be some monsters there so
I was in tons of meetings I mean all of
2021
most of 2021 half of 2022 Not only was I
executing V friends but I invested in
your company I invested Lots ago and I
was in tons of meetings and you know 19
out of every 20 meetings the person on
the other side of the zoom was unable to
answer the second chess move of the
question which is fine I mean people are
going through their a process but you
know what's that second question what's
that question how are you going to
create demand when the market softens
nobody was capable of giving me a fun
answer like almost no one
and if they said well I'll do marketing
you can imagine that's a place where I
feel comfortable when I ask the next
question of like how it would be very
generic look you are sitting here with
the knowledge of us having an actual
business meeting yeah and me giving
actual advice as an investor
nicely yeah
same Heights for my co-founder used to
work at Bingham at Vayner he stood up
any Italian with you and through that
connection we started having a
conversation with Gary we didn't talk
about the future about the media and it
was like
the two out of conversation like I only
got 15 minutes and ended up being a two
hour Jam
it's the version of me that's Gary
vaynerchuk not garyvee when I'm making
content I can only go so deep on a
podcast or a quick piece of tick tock
like you just it is what it is right
obviously the podcast goes deeper
dailyvee was able to go deeper but
there's nothing like an actual business
meeting where we're talking about
private information these are actual
meetings and I you know for me I've
always been more proud of that version
of me than all of the sizzle to me I'm
proud that I'm an actual businessman
it's how I associate with my own self
and yeah I mean I think for everyone
sitting here with their Ambitions and
things of that nature like real [ __ ]
takes time to build
like it it's supposed to be hard if
you're trying to live a one percent of a
one percent life
you know and I think that you know you
got to go through those battles and
those things that I think a lot of
people are going through that right now
I actually think for a lot of people
who've lost money on paper or have lost
actual money it's devastating it hurts
it [ __ ] with your psyche but there's a
lot of people in this room that I'm
looking at that represent the whole
space and to learn these lessons at this
part of your journey is actually
remarkable because it likely doesn't
allow you to make the same mistake twice
it lets you get pattern recognition you
know there's a lot of people who regret
not selling some of their nfts at X
price compared to what it is now maybe
in 12 years when they're investing in
real estate or other things or the stock
market or nfts they'll sense the
patterns and so experience is good
something that doesn't actually kill you
is often a tremendous thing and I think
a lot of people are not seeing the
upside of what's happening right now
they're counting the lost money that was
on paper most people anyway it was just
on paper anyway you don't lose money
until you sell it
and people are going to learn patience
through this and more importantly a lot
of people are going to leave this space
like if this is if like look there is
absolutely whether it happens or not
there's actually indicators that next
year might be very challenging
economically that means we may not be at
the bottom of these prices and a lot of
people who quit their job two years ago
to start in this space may have to get a
job in March or June and there's good
just like the internet when I was in web
2 I was really in a liquor store in New
Jersey for web ones I didn't really know
the Silicon Valley people but as my
career was growing a lot of the people I
met
had left Silicon Valley in 2000 and got
a real job at a t and omnic like you
know and I I think that's the Destiny
for a lot of people here they will leave
a year or two early or five years early
not because they don't believe they just
can't afford it they didn't play it that
way they may not be willing to live that
humbly for five years like everyone
talks about like being about that life
until that life punches you in the
[ __ ] mouth
he's very very very happy so we have a
meeting in January I remember a zoom
call and we were anticipating remember
hey Gary
how do we navigate it down Market
because I'm seeing all the signals it's
coming and there is response to me was
be humble like be okay with time into
God be okay with making tough decisions
what must be humble was it
you stood up multiple businesses your
network is north of 100 million you got
some great track record on investments
just be friends alone 50 million led by
Andrews and horror it's taking it now
from digital into the real world
alienations and Toys R Us you've got the
shoes with rebar you got the whole line
of k-switch yeah you got this whole
literal
I want to call it a kingdom of marketing
right how do you fail because it's so
easy for it to get to your head here you
have no time squads you're always on a
t-shirt you're always who you are how do
you practice your memory
business success doesn't mean [ __ ]
that's how if I die tomorrow I'll trend
on Twitter for 24 hours and then the
next day everybody will move on with
their life
like I just don't think being good at
making money or being a good
entrepreneur enables one to think
they're better than other people I don't
have my validation and my business
success I don't think I'm special in any
shape or form I have much more
validation in what the people that
actually know me feel about me you guys
have some employees that used to work
for me what they think about me because
they actually know me and how I treat
them all the [ __ ] that I spew I live
I believe in kindness I believe in like
good I believe in that stuff and I just
it's very hard for me to think my net
worth or my good investing behaviors or
my ability to navigate and operate
businesses make me any better than any
person on Earth and so
it's just what I believe I just I don't
understand watching people like just
watching people navigate the amount of
[ __ ] douchery that happened in this
space when somebody went from like zero
to like 12 000 Twitter followers and
they thought they were somebody was
[ __ ] asinine not to mention anybody
who's imposing
themselves on someone else based on
anything like money or followers or
status are just showing their hand of
deep insecurity like if you need a blue
check mark to make yourself feel better
you've got some [ __ ] problems and so
I don't you know for me it's because I
had great parenting and I came from
[ __ ] humble beginnings where I knew
that being poor like and being happy was
very real and so like I'm not too tied
up and like that's gonna solve my
problems I really enjoy you know for me
this is about liking people I want to
support you guys I just flew in like I
didn't I [ __ ] crammed this in why why
did I do that I want to support you guys
I like seeing the people like I like
[ __ ] like the seven people I dab up
on the way out as I rush to my meeting
that's nice I I like people that's why
social worked for me that's why life
works for me
humility is very easy when you're a nice
person and you're happy inside
[Applause]
our
name is
and you know what I'm talking about yeah
all right so this is all into business
because no one [ __ ] women you know I I
definitely don't always win but I'm
always but I'm always playing to win
you know like I want to win like I want
my companies to be the biggest I want to
win it's my game like what are we doing
here it's a game I want to win I don't
think that's a bad thing I'm fiercely
competitive however
I do think that for me at least I don't
think my winning comes out of anybody
else's pocket so for me it's like I want
to win but I want everybody else to win
too in the agency land when we pitch a
new piece of business if another agency
wins all right like we lost like we
didn't tell the client what they wanted
here they went somewhere else it's not
like I hate Johnny or Ricky you know I
get pumped watching all these projects
do well I don't think the friends not
being the number one valued project is
bad I
being the number one
is that's going to be the number one
project like I think when all the dust
settles in 22 years you're going to
forget about a lot of names that we [ __ ]
with today and I'm going to be [ __ ]
dominated but if I don't
I'm gonna be pumped for World of women
or board ape or you know whoever like
yeah like I I don't I'm surprised that
people don't know how to balance
trying to be successful and enjoying
their process and loving their game and
being competitive with also being okay
for rooting for everyone else including
people that are direct competitors I
just think the world is abundant and I
I'm gonna get mine nobody's stopping me
from getting mine which is why I cheer
for everybody else to get theirs
that's [ __ ] right
now
you are just announced econ once again
and if you raised 50 million earlier
this year you're now at Macy's Toys R Us
for the next 12 months
next 12 months you know we need to
really execute vcon vcom was such a big
hit last year I think for a lot of
people that were there here and a lot of
people watching I think people got a
sense of like oh [ __ ] that was good and
so I I'm excited because I think a lot
well you know it's weird I was telling
we we are lovingly leveling it up so
much but I said to the team I'm like
we're doing so many things better so
much earlier and it still might not be
better because the gods were just
smiling on us like the size and scale of
that event
and like kind of how naive we went into
it and like you know I've never done
that before like you go through yeah I'm
going through my own first experiences
too like it went so well
yeah I think it's a lot better and I
think it's gonna be great and I really
do hope like everybody here comes
because it's really great like that it's
not only this space it bleeds into like
my community space which I think has an
extra good vibe I really do believe that
it's practical but it's positive and so
we'll do that I we're doing a lot of
Technology work that we have yeah yeah
I think like a few weeks back I did yeah
we're building an internal live platform
I believe in Access both virtual and
physical and I want to control that
entire experience so we've been building
I'm thinking a lot about you know uh
deflation Dynamics so well between book
between book games and series 2B Brands
and series one I've got a lot of nfts
out there and there's a couple things
that I want to put into the world that I
think are really cool for the collection
but I don't want to sell them I want to
reward the people that have already been
in my world so I think we've got some
really cool creative ways to do that
I don't want to give you too many scoops
okay
I mean I just gave it I mean I just gave
it to you like it's there you got it so
we're gonna do that creatively
um but I think more importantly a lot of
the interviews I did early on I was very
active and loud when it was awareness
time and you know I view this as 1980s
after school cartoon world right I've
always compared the nft landscape last
year to after school 80s television
where if you look at the 80s there was a
combination of after school cartoons and
Toys R Us
well my favorite cartoon was probably
Tom and Jerry like because that's what I
was learning English and in America so
that always like has a place in my heart
well I know that I know they didn't talk
Scooby-Doo was big for me but like those
were the cartoons but
you know Transformers My Little Pony The
Rebirth of GI Joe you know Care Bears
you know Thundercats there was a lot of
ips built and I think that's what
happened here I think we'll look in 25
years and I think there'll be 25
meaningful intellectual properties that
happened in 2020 2021 during this year
100 I'm treating this like an
intellectual property I want movies and
amusement parks and cartoons and video
games and Roblox and then I want to
mature it I think it was like Marvel
Marvel started quite young but 30 40
years later there was mature movies
right now the V friends look young I
plan on maturing them over time I I
really am quite confident I think
building the garyvee brand given how
specific of a communicator I am that I'm
just one human being my personality
communication style doesn't hit for
everyone it even turns off a percentage
of people right away that's been a lot
of work for me to 15 years and it's very
narrow getting the world to fall in love
with hot [ __ ] Hornet or rare robot or
patient Panda or empathy elephant is
actually for me easier it will take 20
years but I have a very clear Vision a
really clear team I'm also very
fortunate I've spent the last 13 years
building Vayner you know the quality of
our people some of your partners some of
your employees I have 2 000 Global
employees
30 of the employees at V friends this
year will be from Vayner I don't have to
train them these are six seven ten year
relationships I'm not fooling around
with this [ __ ] this is not like oh I'm
here to have a quick Buck or have a
little bit of fun like this is no
question in my personal mind the
business that puts me in a position to
achieve my life business goal of buying
the New York Jets and so I'm going to
take it very seriously I'm genuinely not
worried about the winter I was born in
[ __ ] Belarus
the winter doesn't [ __ ] scare me
that's right you know what I mean and in
two ways one it's [ __ ] cold in
Belarus and I never wear a jacket and
two I grew up in a [ __ ] [ __ ] place my
family went through a ton of stuff like
a bump in a road like price correction
of digital assets doesn't [ __ ] scare
me I wasn't buying a private plane or a
[ __ ] rolly or anything [ __ ] Fancy
with the Make Pretend money I don't need
that [ __ ] I need the process to build my
[ __ ] I need the game I need to be an
entrepreneur it's who I am not because
it's a [ __ ] fad now because it's
always been who I've been even when it
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] thing to do in the
80s 90s and 2000 so I'm just living my
[ __ ] life doing my thing genuinely
not worried about the cheering or the
booing I'm gonna [ __ ] execute I have
no interest in debating anybody about
anything I'll see you in 2037 and we'll
calculate the [ __ ] score let's
[ __ ] go oh yeah
that's what it is
crypto books in your wallet
I think 61. 61 crypto phones you also
triggered a run on the crypto funds you
ended up buying a pump for a couple of
seven figure pumps right yeah from day
one I was like man so punks punks is the
only project including be friends
that I'm 100 on 100 because with me
friends I could die and if I don't
execute the demand then it doesn't play
out
pot so Apes world of women you know
every project all of them they all have
to execute
punks doesn't have to execute [ __ ]
that's why you notice when [ __ ] gets
hairy punks always kinds to move and
everything else Punk says history it's a
[ __ ] artifact it's a it's got history
on its side it doesn't have to execute
and so that's why for me that's been and
all the older projects skulls which I
know caused a lot of hoop a lot like
crypto Strikers like I like the older
stuff because they don't have to do [ __ ]
all the new stuff all of us have to do a
ton of [ __ ] a ton from my project to the
other top 100 projects cats Penguins all
of them everybody has to execute for a
decade in my opinion just to justify
what the [ __ ] they're worth right now
so think about that so with punks that
was why I saw that I'm like this is
forever this is the history one this is
the safest and that's where I went and
what is my favorite nfts outside
it's really challenging for me to answer
that right now I'll tell you why I have
been in a complete v-friends cocoon and
I think a lot of people in this space
know this I've been trying to like be
out there a little bit but I'm like so
deeply aware that if I don't navigate
this time properly
not wasting money okay you know uh
grabbing M A opportunities as people go
out of business acquiring the best
talent building out the value
proposition thinking about things like
the burning mechanics deflationary
thinking about things like the added
value that I'm creating for the people
that hold it like working
the number one thing I promised myself
six years ago when I was like oh [ __ ] I
think I'm gonna be known by a lot of
people and that just comes with a lot of
baggage was don't talk about [ __ ] ever
ever ever that you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about do not have a
receipt on the internet where you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
receipts
and just have me always most on tilt and
most hype so this is just the truth I
have been so out of the loop for the
last 10 months watching every other
project because I've been so focused and
really focused on ours that it scares me
to answer that question because I
haven't really thought it as a matter of
fact one of the things I'm most excited
about for this holiday is I'm gonna have
some down time I have this nice little
chunk of like seven days where I really
have down time and I'm not really great
at just laying down and not doing [ __ ]
I'm like oh yeah I'm very sure so I'm
really excited to actually like do do a
back track of what's been going on for
the last nine months like who did this
and why and who did that and why and so
like right now I don't have my finger on
the pulse of like what cool cats or
Doodles or apes or world of women or any
of the projects are doing or who are the
come up people I I still have a lot of
passion for one of one artists I think
there's a lot there to uncover I think
when you kind of look in 15 years like
who was it it was like oh [ __ ] while we
were looking at all these 10K Avatar
projects there was these six artists
doing one of ones that that was the
actual collectible thing to do so I'm
intrigued by that space I'm intrigued by
the tech you know warm wallets hot
wallets cold wallets icy wallets like
there's a lot of fun stuff there I think
the whole thing with like people getting
educated on like what is decentralized
versus not back to like not talking
about [ __ ] I don't know when the FTX
thing happened I get bombarded CNBC Wall
Street Journal I'm like I don't [ __ ]
know anything about that people like I
never even looked at one
One exchange I didn't spend a minute I
have not spent one minute on exchanges
because my brain was always like well
that's not that's not the thing like
that's not that's not the thing so I
just didn't even like spend time on it
so I have nothing to say on that because
I other than fraud is [ __ ] the worst
you know but like so you know I think
I'm just focused on that so the answer
is I'm not sure which is again for all
the [ __ ] hoopla when I was doing it
like even I'm actually kind of itchy to
buy some [ __ ] and what am I looking at
2017 18 and 19 projects I still I'm
still more excited about buying a plasma
bear that was made by x copy than I am
about like something that came out in
2021 that has to execute perfectly for
17 years to justify its current floor
price we have not hit zero
every project could openc number 300 and
down right now if we go click on it and
this is the 300th rank one then the
400th rank gun then the 500. every one
of those that are like 200 for that's
going to a penny
it just can't sustain it it's just math
and so like to me that's what I think
about all right so we have two minutes
left
let's do quick rapid fire and then I
want to hear from you what is going to
be your legacy
I can answer that right now that I that
I gave more than I took
and that I gave a real real real [ __ ]
swing at it to teach people that you can
be kind while being ambitious that you
can be incredibly selfless while being
okay with being selfish for you and your
family I'm going to give that a real run
for 40 years from here on out 50 more
years from here on out and I'd like to
think that that's what my legacy was
most successful
most successful failure
you know probably I won't go too deep
because we're running out of time but
there was a lot of failing that happened
for me being in business with my dad and
my brother that like on paper seemingly
is failing for me economically and I
would argue that it's the only thing in
my life that I would never change
because it was so successful because my
relationship with my dad and my brother
is so off the [ __ ] charts and amazing
and it really like I have a lot of
passion to write a family business book
before I die because I think people
completely misplay it and there's a lot
of things that are completely not talked
about that I would love to see you be
more popularized
garage sales or restore qualities
they're the same game so this is so hard
garage sales in the summer
because like I can go out and do it and
there's just something about that 5 30
in the morning coffee and I'm like I'm
gonna [ __ ] find the rarest toy of all
time but in the winter when I can't
garage sale there's nothing like going
and doing a little exploring in some of
the old Discord anthropology stuff and
so that's fun all right
um
everything you think is right
you know I think and I'll and I'll make
it valuable to everybody let me tell you
what that's grounded in that I'd love to
push everyone here to rely on just a
little bit more
I think we do not have a strong
contemporary conversation in our society
around intuition it seems impractical it
seems a little too foofy what 30 year
old me had is what 47 year old me has
right this second a deep
fear to not listen to my intuition
that's the greatest fear you're not
listening to myself and I actually
disrupts my sleep my patterns and if I
don't listen to my intuition everything
breaks let me tell everybody here why
it's a big one the thing that sucks the
most
is losing on someone else's sword
what's cool about intuition is when you
[ __ ] up at least you did your thing so
many people here listen to someone else
and it didn't work out and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucks
right so if we can get more into
intuition I think that would really help
and that's what I would tell the
audience thank you everyone
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]